[Music]
did you break it i'll turn it off for
now
i don't know what's going on
monkey
what are we doing
we're here
yeah
so they are making kimchi chicken
yes just kidding kimchi chicken
oh come on
don't do that that's disgusting
so thank you tyka thinks it's funny when
a bunch of inappropriate jokes are made
like boo boo pee pee
pee pee
he thinks that's all hilarious because
we gotta go oh dude don't do that
so that's where we're at in life but
going back to the cooking
what are you making wait have you ever
made it before i have it so i'm just
gonna make a modified version of it it's
not gonna be authentic but it will be
bomb
like everything that i make
and some of these
it's kind of cool because like these
stews
i think they were invented
for old produce you know what i mean and
we have a ton of old wilted produce why
let it go to waste
we might as well eat and have diarrhea
yeah as a family yeah together
i'm gonna cut it up and you wash it okay
teamwork so so far what taika has done
he helped me boil the water
he helped me put some salt in there i'm
not gonna cut it up first and then
and he helped me put some kimchi
up in the heezy
hey turn off the water yeah the water is
making me you're watching nothing dude
baby
did you just say monkey cheetah papa has
to cut it out at first look at how
disorganized your papa is after you wash
it then where does it go
what do you mean it goes straight into
the bowl
what bowl the one on the pot
but he's just gonna be washing dirty
over the queen
wait what what's dirty over the do you
speak english the dirty cabbage over the
clean cabbage
wait wait wait what are you talking
about the cabbage that he washes yeah
does it just stay in there
until he's done washing all over the top
this is dirt right there
[Music]
yeah your mom's right right i'm his wife
my mom monkey
i'm his wife i'm your mom
yes just kidding you got to be very
careful you can't mess around with these
sharp knives
open it so you can throw it away
ready
oh thank you you're so smart there you
go
thank you monkey thank you we're gonna
play with it
are you ready hey you have to wash it
okay i open a little bit so he doesn't
waste all that water so i just barely
let a trickle happen that's too much put
your two little hands in like this a
little bit more yeah like two little
hands and he knows
he knows what to do monkey tell him we
do this with mom all the time
yeah i know what to do
what are you talking about
stop saying that
it's in the jeans
he got that from a jackie chan movie
really yeah
oh the jet level oh gently the master
don't blame it on my jackie
i'm sorry you're jackie hey yeah
look at this
it's crying tofu tears
tofu peepee
whoa
hey you gotta be careful
okay you got to be careful man
did you put it all back in there no
watch it real good okay okay okay
i heard what you were about to say what
was he about to say
[Music]
oh you're totally gonna eat that
wait is it like gelatinous oh no it's
water right no it's mold water
come on dude i'm not about to eat that
either you're talking about essay
that's super gross yeah i did like a
sponge grill
i'm just kidding i'm gonna eat it not me
you're totally gonna eat it too dude hey
do you want to go to timeout do you want
to do 20 burpees
why did you do that why did you stick
your tongue out
that's rude you don't do that
why did you do that i don't know you
know in some countries when you stick
your tongue out they go
and their tongue is gone yeah you want
papa to cut your tongue
and they throw it in someone's cereal
and then you're gonna eat it
yeah then don't do it again
okay that does not give me confidence at
all dude oh come on
well i'm scared it smells like wine
that's not good that's not good how do
you know i don't know
wine is fermented wine is fermented yeah
once you so is kimchi
yeah but in a in a purposeful way this
wasn't this is just because it's old no
it's fine it's like cured it's ready
once you boil it it's fine everything is
fine
so this is
me documenting my last supper
i am not very sure that i will make it
to tomorrow
so i just want to tell everybody
my mom
my brother my sisters
that i loved you
i loved you with all of my heart and i
wish it didn't end like this i wish that
bart didn't kill me with this poisonous
mushroom but
this is hella cute
oh i missed it for dinner for being an
idiot
what do you do okay turn on the water
you betrayed him
he feels so betrayed watch your face
dude it's hot close the closet
you can you can move the butt big cuties
i like how every time he goes back and
forth he has to move his little doggie
too much you got to be gentle look okay
like that there you go
okay now come over here
whoa oh
yeah hey don't don't close don't get too
close oh he knows he knows you know
right bunky yeah look i'm trying to get
oh he's here look i'm here oh i'm coming
i'm coming in i didn't get almost
watch your head i know you're not in the
way duty thank you i can see my love
mama yes
i see an orange i see orange now yeah
it's all changed to orange yeah no it's
lava
so this way alrighty what's happening
now so now we're going to boil the meat
so you don't get all that meat i believe
the correct term is skunk
oh like that stuff on the top
excuse me
check it out dude
you are so right
kind of hall monitory but you're very
right dude okay you wash your hands yeah
use your hands but afterwards we have to
wash it okay okay throw it in there
don't throw it in there don't listen to
what he's saying put it in gently gently
i can't believe you said throw it in
there
watch the plastic it's gonna burn watch
what you're doing you can't you go like
this you like this give him the tongs
dude okay wait he doesn't know how to
use tongs you know how strong these
things are
here monkey let's try it okay use that
oh it's getting a bigger big big hand in
there
okay that's why
kids
are made from the mama's belly
yeah the plastic is going to burn again
they get the love
but you guys are fun for sure but they
get the toughness
from
the mom
did you guys rub soap on you didn't
he just did jiu jitsu in that hey don't
rub it on your head here you do you made
your mother rub it okay
one two three four five okay that's it
keep your hands out this is what a
surgeon and a chef
okay you can't help me then i have to
put it in
then stop doing that once you're done
you have to go like this surgeons and
and chef they go like that so don't
touch anything
okay
okay
leave it maybe like that like a surgeon
and a chef
okay let's go i'm over here this is not
fun you have to bring a dog
and then
you're going to put it gently i saw what
you did gently in there okay
get the tongs man gently
gently
don't splash this will be hot it's gonna
burn your face off there you go
there you go no pressure tyco
get right
in for your whole body now okay hurry
hurry hurry
are you are you murdering the cabbage
are those the cabbage screaming yeah
they're scared of water
they're taking a bath
it was a hobby there you go
look at that
ah look at that one okay let me see let
me go let me see
no that's just gonna burn just leave it
it's lost let me get a chopsticks oh
what
wood ones huh
awesome
chinese kung fu look at that
kind of coffee yep it is
the wet with the head
watch oh dude careful the mouth not the
hand
oh watch the hands not the
mouth
don't wash them
okay that's it
and then we mix it you want to mix it
yeah okay
use your hand okay slowly right remember
up here yep slowly
there we go but deep down deep in there
like that oh
okay let me move over
it's kind of cramped
oh no no no we're gonna try it
we need more a little more water okay
look at that okay now we're gonna turn
that one down look see
turn it down and then poke it down like
this what get down there now let me know
it was too far i like to look see look
at that okay you do it push it down push
it get in there
watch your wrist okay because you can
burn it watch it okay watch down here
because you're really close to the
middle you're good that's it
and then what do you do shake it twice a
little bit one okay no shake like this
when they take it out like this you go
and put it back there yep and then let's
get some more water careful okay can't
move up move away and let me come back
i love this little doggie
that's too little
watch your wrist okay i want you to burn
yourself
what to do you and your dad make me so
nervous
hey kids surprised with single down
today
exactly dude hey okay now we're gonna
move all that stuff over her okay plural
it's the red the marshmallow
marshmallows it's tofu oh no
oh the whole thing
is no no let me use my okay don't throw
it okay because it's going to splash
there you go gentle
okay
gentle gentle come on
don't crush them
you want to eat them together okay good
job i did i did a lot
i saw what you did who taika what'd you
do monkey look at his chest
oh we got stuff all over your chest for
and then we gotta put on some thank you
dates
some danky tanks
dump it okay
slowly
watch your hands okay
it's gonna be so spicy it won't gonna be
spicy okay trust me trust me well
what
the thanks and then more danky dinks
more danky tanks
like
this crab i mean this seafood base or
soup base
let me see how to smell it first see if
it smells right
this is danky dank though how much are
you gonna put in there
it seems gross
no but when you put in the soup it turns
today
okay do one
at a time one at a time yep watch your
hands though yeah
no you got to stick it in here like this
no no i know i'll help you i'll help you
look okay ready
slow slow closer
there we
go i think okay one more okay
slow slow slow slow down
okay
look at that
look at that and that will turn into mud
look at that it's so stinky
it's so stingy but look i'm not gonna
mix it
be careful
i know but i gotta let me do them here
you do it then
do a little bit oh you always don't let
me do stuff oh i want you to do it but
look but you destroy it yeah don't smash
it don't smash the toe
look what look at papa how papa does it
looks like a circle in circles like this
okay what's happening monkey the bubbles
are doing what they're doing
and
so these bubbles in here yeah
they're doing what they're done like how
and then
who's your dad monkey
oh
that guy huh
i wonder where you got it from
okay wait so what's the tofu doing again
now what's going on i'm gonna try yeah
i'm just i'm cutting it and then you can
stir it okay
little wait a second i'm going to cut it
and you can stir it okay
and then you cut it
no there's no way
i have one brain you see how my left arm
is listening to my right arm both your
arms don't even listen to your own brain
yet look at that you're dead barely
your hands are crying like crying all
right if i do it do it dude your hands
are crying watch your arm
what happened
you didn't burn anything
okay lift it up high high high oh yeah
don't let it go peppa's putting it
spider-man's thirsty from all that
yapping has been doing
how'd it taste i heard it i heard a
slurp
not bad i think it needs a little bit
more of this broth
and i think it's pretty good it's
actually not bad yeah
i'm gonna make a little bit of sesame
oil oh yeah dude
let me see whoa
you love orange juice huh
yeah me too when i was a kid orange
juice was my favorite juice i didn't
like pineapple juice i didn't like apple
juice
i didn't like any of those i like plain
apple juice i did really good with that
you like what apple juice um like was
like a plant and the apple i like that
one plant and an apple yeah and that's
kind of and then i like that one oh okay
how about you papa what was your
favorite juice growing up
when i first started i liked watered
down apple juice i always felt like
water uh apple juice was too small right
me too
when you were kidding me
and that was fun
[Applause]
i thought they're like in the night
shower's mama when i was a kid
and then then what are you right now and
then you button it
and
drink it oh oh
when we would go
to a juice shop and we would drink it
together huh
q and me yeah you would water it down
you would dilute it
yeah and then um
when i got introduced to more of the
fancier juices i really like peach white
grape
um
and then like the mixing of juices like
you know like a hawaii pog oh yeah yeah
like that stuff guava so good yeah guava
juice
sure
yeah he made it for you i made it just
for you
wait what was that do it again
[Music]
he just hit us with that i don't know
where i do netfish i love it
in the class how cute you memorized it
so this is usually what happens when
kids get excited to help parents
parents stay doing everything
the kids are gone
i love you dude
i love you dude
my favorite
all right vato
all right now what are you doing
i'm serving the little monkey dude
because you're scared of the heat
charlie which is pretty funny for a chef
um so we always have to serve him first
well his little mouth his little mouth
receptacles
hey that's not the way i was talking the
way i was taught is this is how you're
supposed to eat i know but i love you
adjust your mouth
but i love you
i mean i love him
what does that mean then i'm taking care
of it so we're holding him back and
cuddling him
no i'm just kidding
so oh you want to try some of the broth
see if you like it i'll like it not here
try it try it from the straight from the
horse's mouth holy crap you better blow
on that really hard that [ __ ] looks v
sauce
oh yeah
it's not that hot
or messed up
it's definitely not kimchi
what is it
no clue but it's not bad it tastes good
why why what makes it not kimchi chicken
it's on the sweeter side
sweeter
i don't put no sugar in this i know but
it tastes sweeter
damn
yeah are you kidding me you kidding me
cuny what do you do that for
what exactly are you doing i just cut it
up for him because uh
he doesn't like two bigger things in his
mouth and he's got a little jaw still oh
so somebody else is cuddling him i see i
know i don't like it i don't like it
there you are the man with the scissors
i don't think you're cuddling or i'm
cuddling all right what do you think
we're doing
loving on the dude look at him
big cutie
you're so lucky i can't believe you
snuck that ipad out
because he never watches his ipad unless
it's like a special occasion
or he's been like really good and he
gets all his not chores he doesn't have
chores but he's just a good boy not that
he's bad i'm using the wrong words what
is what is it when does he get it um
he's always a good boy it's just when he
doesn't make bad decision and gets
himself in trouble
that's what i'm trying to say
okay so now we got an ice cube in there
yeah i'm cuddling because because i know
i'm cause i'm
freeze straining his lips
and he's i need to step on the nerves
and
he's dying
that's why he's so happy someone dies
oh my goodness
well she got a double duck that's crazy
you better look away
no i'm looking at her
who designed this chicks you see this
chick don't talk about it
can you stop looking he's looking at her
die
you're missing the point she's squat
you're missing the point dude
dude she's wearing white underwear
okay time for you to eat it
oh
okay i just want to remind you you just
spin it out like that oh i missed it it
was too hot why did you spit it out like
that monkey you cooked that do you like
what you made
oh you cooked it
it's not spicy
how about you you think it's too spicy
oh it's not bad no it's good it's not
bad at all i didn't think it was bad at
all well i just thought it was like
because we just grabbed a bunch of
scraps so i don't know what was going to
turn out to be yeah but there's some
good scratches that's not bad at all
it's not bad at all do you think it
tastes like kimchi chicken because i do
have broken taste buds no
right like it's a it's a bomb stew
but from what i understand from david
is that all kimchi jiggas are different
oh because it is
trash food
it's like a leftover food leftover food
yeah so like every mom is gonna have
different stuff because every mom cooks
with different things right right right
right throw some green onions yeah or
whatever yeah
so because remember wait at his house i
was like wow
i've never had like this before yeah
well he actually cooks not true i'm just
kidding it's actually really really good
pretty good
bikini throw on some seaweed no i like
that this is really good okay seaweed
no i said i'm going to go get it
so i guess i liked it more than i
thought what
why would you say that it was really
good
i don't know i just thought like
something that i didn't intend to make i
know i like making stews with scraps and
stuff but this time i was really really
um scarce on it like i didn't have my
usual garlic
my onions
and if i like making any type of these
stews i like to throw a couple pieces of
spam in there oh we had spam i have to
throw that in there oh really i was damn
i haven't been in the pantry in a long
time oh you don't snack the wait time in
iceland no i just go in there just to
grab like my protein shake and my
pre-workout that's it but really
yeah
am i disciplining this you call
this
discipline
the diet of this
oh my goodness that looks like santa
claus
have a little bit there
anyways thank you guys for cooking with
me and the young spider chef right here
the spidey
well i liked it he didn't like it you
know what you made it though you made it
you made it but thank you guys for
watching if you guys want to see more
cooking videos with me and the chef
let me know see you guys next time peace